si vemos esta molécula esperaríamos tres
señales en un espectro de rm en este
protón tiene un desplazamiento químico
de 7.2 partes por millón
este protón está en un ambiente un poco
distinto por lo que obtenemos un
desplazamiento químico ligeramente
diferente de 6.7 estos tres protones son
equivalentes y por ende nos dan una
señal con un desplazamiento químico de
3.9 partes por millón basándonos en lo
que sabemos hasta ahora esperaríamos el
espectro de rm de arriba
estos tres protones nos dan una señal en
un desplazamiento químico de 3.9 esa
sería esta señal de aquí hagamos al
siguiente protón rojo este protón aquí
en rojo tiene un desplazamiento de 6.7
por lo que esperaríamos esta señal y
luego el último protón aquí lo pondré en
azul
éste está en 7.2 este es mi espectro rm
esperado con lo que sabemos hasta
ahorita pero este de hecho no es el
espectro rm en el espectro rm n es este
de abajo
aún vemos esta señal con un pico para
los protones en verde pero si vemos esta
señal para el protón en rojo en la
versión de arriba tenemos una señal con
un pico en la versión de abajo esa señal
se ha dividido en dos picos déjame
continuar resaltando los aquí hay un
pico y acá hay otro pico por lo que la
señal se dividirá en dos picos
exactamente lo mismo pasa con el protón
en azul tenemos una señal con un pico en
la versión de arriba y por aquí abajo
esa señal para el protón azul se
dividirá en dos picos llamamos a esto
desdoblamiento espn espn o acoplamiento
espn espn y veamos con más detalle qué
está pasando con ese protón rojo y ese
protón azul vamos aquí abajo donde
tenemos más espacio continuamos
dibujando el espectro sin interacción
entre los protones
la primera versión de la que hablamos
donde esperábamos una señal con un pico
en 6.7 partes por millón y ese fue el
protón en rojo y luego esperamos una
señal con un pico en 7.25 partes por
millón y ese era el protón en azul esta
versión de arriba es el espectro sin
interacción entre nuestros dos protones
pero en la realidad si hay una
interacción porque recuerda que el
protón en rojo el momento magnético del
protón en rojo puede ir hacia arriba o
hacia abajo podría estar alineado con el
campo magnético externo o podría estar
alineado en el sentido contrario del
campo magnético
el protón en rojo tiene un momento
magnético o un campo magnético yendo
hacia arriba o hacia abajo y entonces
pensemos en el ejemplo donde el momento
magnético del protón en rojo está
alineado con el campo externo primero
tenemos nuestro protón en rojo y digamos
que el momento magnético está alineado
con el campo magnético externo déjame
continuar y dibujar el campo magnético
externo de esta manera así que llamamos
a este de cero y estos dos vectores van
en la misma dirección el campo magnético
del protón en rojo se suma al campo
magnético externo y déjame continuar
dibujando un vector más grande aquí
porque ahora el campo magnético efectivo
sentido por el protón en azul ha
aumentado
por lo que el campo magnético efectivo
es más grande que el campo magnético
aplicado porque el campo magnético del
protón en rojo se le está sumando
y entonces el protón en azul siente un
campo magnético efectivo mayor y
recuerda lo que eso hace a la diferencia
de energía entre los estados de espín
alfa y beta si incrementas el campo
magnético incrementas la diferencia en
energía entre los estados de espina alfa
y beta por lo tanto obtienes una señal
de frecuencia más alta y un
desplazamiento químico más alto de lo
esperado esto tiene el efecto de
incrementar
ves
o sea
bien
todo
químico para el protón en azul podemos
dibujar el protón en azul en un
desplazamiento químico más alto de lo
esperado bien hagamos lo mismo pero esta
vez pensemos que el campo magnético del
protón en rojo se alinea en contra del
campo magnético aplicado esta es la
situación donde el campo magnético del
protón en rojo va hacia abajo eso es en
la dirección opuesta del campo magnético
aplicado estoy dibujando el campo
magnético aplicado aquí y entonces el
campo magnético del protón en rojo se
cancelará sumándose con el campo
magnético externo y el protón en azul
siente un campo magnético efectivo menor
estoy exagerando aquí solo para llegar
al punto pero el protón en azul siente
un campo magnético efectivo menor que
disminuye la diferencia en energía entre
los estados de espín alfa y beta por lo
tanto obtienes una señal de frecuencia
más baja y un valor menor para el test
miento
químico el esperado un valor menor de
desplazamiento químico para el protón
azul
continuaré dibujando la señal para el
protón azul y un valor menor para el
desplazamiento químico y entonces el
resultado final es que la señal para el
protón azul se divide en dos la señal
para el protón azul se separa en dos
debido a los dos campos magnéticos
diferentes del protón rojo y el protón
azul también tiene un campo magnético
apuntando arriba o abajo y entonces el
protón azul divide la señal para el
protón rojo de la misma manera podemos
continuar dibujando al protón rojo
dividiéndose de la misma manera y
entonces esto de abajo representa el
espectro donde ambos protones están
acoplados el uno con el otro
llamamos a esto acoplamiento y entonces
acabamos viendo que la señal se dividió
en dos picos diferentes
a la cual llamamos doblete vayamos por
aquí y veamos a nuestros protones otra
vez el protón en rojo se divide en dos
picos la señal se divide en dos picos de
los que hablamos aquí y para el protón
en azul la señal se dividió en dos picos
de esta manera de los cuales hablamos
aquí esa es la idea del desdoblamiento
espn espn y a continuación veremos otro
ejemplo el cual es sólo un poco más
complicado pero usa exactamente esta
misma idea veamos esta molécula este
protón tiene un desplazamiento químico
de 5.7 partes por millón y los protones
aquí en rojo son equivalentes y
esperaríamos una señal a 3.95 partes por
millón esperamos una señal debido a dos
protones a 3.95 esto de aquí representa
dos protones
y esperamos una señal para un protón a
5.77 esta señal no es tan intensa porque
solo representa un protón si los
protones rojos y azules no interactúan
unos con otros
esperaríamos esto como el espectro de rm
n del protón pero si interactúan uno con
otro y entonces tenemos que pensar en
los momentos magnéticos de los dos
protones rojos podría pensar en el
primer protón rojo teniendo un momento
magnético que apunta hacia arriba y el
segundo protón rojo teniendo un momento
magnético que también apunta hacia
arriba
esta es una posible combinación de
momentos magnéticos otra posible
combinación podría tener este primer
protón rojo teniendo un momento
magnético apuntando hacia arriba y el
segundo protón rojo teniendo un momento
magnético apuntando hacia abajo o el
primer protón apuntando hacia abajo y un
segundo protón apuntando hacia
dos posibles combinaciones de spin más
la última combinación de spin sería por
supuesto el momento magnético del primer
protón hacia abajo así como el del
segundo protón esto representa las
posibles combinaciones de momentos
magnéticos o campos magnéticos para los
dos protones en rojo tomemos la primera
combinación posible
pensemos en ambos protones teniendo
momentos magnéticos apuntando hacia
arriba
digamos que nuestro campo magnético
aplicado o campo magnético externo
apunta en la misma dirección
cuando hablas del campo magnético
experimentado por el protón en azul
sumaríamos los campos magnéticos de los
protones en rojo y entonces el campo
magnético efectivo ha incrementado es
más alto que el campo magnético aplicado
hemos incrementado el campo magnético
experimentado por el protón en azul por
lo tanto incrementando la diferencia en
energía entre tus estados de espn alfa y
beta incrementando tu frecuencia y
teniendo una vez
pimiento
químico más alto entonces podemos pensar
en el desplazamiento químico siendo más
alto y dibujando eso de esta manera
pasando el 5.77 veamos las siguientes
dos posibles combinaciones ésta
y está tuvimos el momento magnético
arriba para el primer protón el momento
magnético hacia abajo para el segundo
protón y luego abajo para el primero y
arriba para el segundo
qué efecto tienen esos campos magnéticos
en el campo magnético esperado sentido
por el protón en azul pensamos en la
primera combinación esta combinación de
aquí tenemos un campo magnético hacia
arriba y un campo magnético hacia abajo
se cancelaría lo mismo pasa con esta
combinación uno hacia abajo y uno hacia
arriba esos campos magnéticos se
cancelarían y entonces el campo
magnético efectivo sentido por el protón
en azul es igual al campo magnético
externo
porque los campos magnéticos de los
protones se cancelan unos con otros
así que esperaríamos una señal en el
desplazamiento químico apropiado
esperaríamos una señal en el
desplazamiento químico correcto en 5.77
y esta señal será de hecho más intensa
que esta señal y eso es debido a la
probabilidad hay una probabilidad mayor
de tener una de estas combinaciones de
campos magnéticos que tener estas
combinaciones el doble de probabilidades
te da una señal de doble intensidad en
el desplazamiento químico correcto
finalmente veamos la última combinación
ambos campos magnéticos apuntando hacia
abajo ambos campos magnéticos para los
protones en rojo apuntando hacia abajo y
tenemos nuestro campo magnético aplicado
apuntando hacia arriba por lo que el
campo magnético efectivo sentido por el
protón en azul es más
pequeño cierto tenemos un valor menor
para el campo magnético efectivo
disminuimos el campo magnético sentido
por el protón en azul disminuyendo la
diferencia de energía disminuyendo la
frecuencia disminuyendo el
desplazamiento químico cierto
esperaríamos zoom
a
tú
químico menor podemos continuar
incluyendo un desplazamiento químico más
bajo de esta manera veamos esta señal de
aquí a arriba dijimos que esperaríamos
una señal para el protón en azul pero
esa señal es afectada por el campo
magnético de los diferentes protones en
rojo y las posibles combinaciones de los
momentos magnéticos de los protones en
rojo toman la señal para el protón en
azul y te da tres picos tenemos un pico
en un desplazamiento químico más alto un
pico de doble intensidad en el
desplazamiento químico correcto y un
pico de intensidad más baja y entonces
si ves el espectro de rm n esta es la
señal para el protón en azul la señal se
dividió en tres picos uno dos y tres y
llamamos a esto un triplete este es
triple p qué pasa con los protones en
rojo los protones en rojo son afectados
por los campos magnéticos del protón en
azul y el campo magnético del protón en
azul puede alinearse tanto con el campo
magnético externo o en contra del campo
magnético externo es como el ejemplo que
vimos anteriormente dos posibles campos
magnéticos para el protón en azul debido
a esto la señal para los protones en
rojo se divide en dos cierto
obtenemos una señal para los protones en
rojo dividida en dos y dibujar eso aquí
la señal se divide en dos picos la señal
para los protones en rojo se divide en
dos picos y llamamos a esto
t
veremos más del desdoblamiento espn espn
en el siguiente vídeo